Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
August 10th,
2015.
How's it going?
How are you?
What are you doing?
Huh?
It's Monday.
Do you get droid?
He listened to it on the way home on the way there.
I put it up earlier this week,
or at least I tried to,
I have my brand new,
uh,
I switched internet carriers because it just wasn't getting any,
it's taken me forever to upload these podcasts and I'm all syked now.
So,
and I got this new fucking Internet,
right?
It's such a racket.
You know,
my old Internet soft in every room in the house.
My New Internet is unbelievable in the living room and you can't get any
connection anywhere else.
Nowhere else will the fucking light you on.
And it's frustrating.
But uh,
but whatever,
I uploaded my Thursday podcast,
it uploaded in like 17 seconds and it usually was taking me like a half hour to
upload 30 fucking minutes.
Um,
just cause where I live,
there's does,
you know,
to low signal,
which evidently isn't a bad thing because I just ran into this fucking leg
and she was telling me all this shit about fucking electromagnetic shit passing
through your fucking head and was telling me,
ah yeah,
turn off your router every night,
give you your body a chance to get rid of all of this shit.
And uh,
I who,
who the fuck knows,
you know,
I guess when she was trying to claim,
but when you,
when you signed that fucking apple agreement,
there's something that you never read.
You just sign it that there's something in there that basically says,
yeah,
if this laptop gives you a ball cancer or fucking brain cancer with the phone,
you can't sue us and all of that type of shit.
Which is totally believable cause all they gotta do is just push that through
congress and none of those cons make any money and they need the money or the
rich people.
So they go,
hey,
you want to fucking still be in office?
Well though.
Yeah,
you still want that side pace in your own private subway over the fucking thing.
They're right of the capitol,
the past,
his God damn pill.
And they go,
all right.
It's why we have fucking a income tax.
It's why we have all of this fucking shits.
Why I love Donald Trump.
Yeah.
During that Republican debate,
he actually have to shit you cons told me I should be walking around with tin
foil on my head.
He fucking said it during the debate.
He goes,
you give a politician money,
they'll do whatever you want.
And he goes,
I've given everybody money up here on this panel.
And it was like 10 guys and only one guy goes,
that's fucking hilarious.
They'll do whatever you want.
So they go,
well,
what'd you give it to the Clintons for?
What did they want?
He goes,
I wanted Hillary to go to my wedding.
And you know what?
The bitch showed up.
She fucking showed up.
So there you go.
I don't know what the fuck that has to do with routers,
but I feel vindicated.
All you cops forever was sitting there telling me that I got my fucking,
uh,
my tin foil hat on because I didn't think it made a bit of difference whether
you're voted in a fucking republican or a Democrat,
because you know,
those fucking cops got enough money to put money on both horses so there's
shit's still getting pushed through.
Right.
That's why when they go on the fucking debates,
they don't talk about the population problem.
They don't talk about genetically altered food.
They don't talk about fucking anything running out of water.
They know all they talk about is fucking broads,
getting jobs and education and fucking whatever the fuck we're doing over there,
it's supporting the tropes.
You know what I mean?
Hey,
am I out of my fucking mind here?
It didn't.
We defeat Germany and Japan and like three and a half,
four years.
It's like four and a half years.
Well,
I'm with the Italians and whoever else was with the fucking Germans.
Right?
We got that fucker.
We got a world war.
We got a fucking world war done collectively.
When the fuck did it start 39 40.
It was over by 45,
five years.
We've got the shit over with.
What are we doing now?
We're all there with these fucking console they got as a jungle gym.
Okay.
15 years in his shift,
14 fucking years into it.
You want,
it was what the World War II was.
We had no intentions of taking over the country and staying there.
That's what it is.
We have an occupation going on here.
So what are you going to do?
You're fucking there.
You know,
you're over there trying to build a Starbucks,
you know,
put up a staples.
You know,
you just got to be constantly engaged with the enemy over there.
I Dunno man.
What a fuck do I get off talking about something that big?
You know,
why?
Cause there's my podcast.
What are you gonna do about it?
I'll tell you what you gonna do against.
Sit right there and you got to fucking listen to it.
Okay?
Oh,
not you.
Shut it off.
I don't give a shit.
Um,
anyway,
so I finally have some good Internet.
Never deadly.
Uh,
cause I went from 0.3 megabytes per minute signal.
Now I have like 300 per minute.
Now I get up a load of podcasts in two seconds,
but I'll probably gonna fucking die in like a year and a half from the fucking
beam that's coming from the thing that floats over your house out there in
space.
Right?
The satellite.
How come fucking Steve Jobs died of cancer?
Pancreatic cancer.
You know what that was from,
right?
All those years,
they haven't that laptop sitting on his stomach because he was trying to beat
all Billy Gates.
Right?
And there he is having a signed a fucking agreement.
This might give you cancer.
And he got,
he got fucking,
you got killed by his own monster.
It's like one of those Frankenstein movies,
right?
Fucking laptop picked him right up and throw them right in the lake.
It'll Steve,
he couldn't swim.
Cody.
Nope.
They had those gray,
new balance.
Just weighing him down.
Took him right down to the bottom of a goat.
Died an angry man.
One I heard.
What'd you have that built up by?
Some guy who didn't fucking know him.
So I hear most of my shit.
Um,
anyways,
so I have not boozed.
Oh,
oh.
I miss itself.
Somebody gave me the green light to booze too.
I was like,
well,
you know,
I'm not an alcoholic,
but I was definitely drinking like one and this person was like,
well,
I came from a family of alcoholics.
When you drink,
does it get in the way of your life?
Because it's your life.
You're not able to function if you don't have it.
I was like,
no.
She goes,
no,
you're not an alcoholic.
I was like,
that was fucking great.
Can you do that the next time I get fat?
Can you tie your shoes?
Yeah.
Well you're going to fet.
Okay.
Can you just keep eating a banana split?
Who the fuck orders a banana split past the age of like six or seven?
Are you out of your fucking mind?
What do you try?
Don't you just stick a gun in your mouth?
Spin the barrel and pull the trigger.
Fucking banana split.
You.
What's funny about the banana split the back in the day that was like you
ordered every flavor of ice cream.
You know back in the day there was vanilla,
strawberry,
and chocolate.
That was it.
And he got it from the farmer down the street and there was no fucking
electromagnetic bullshit flying through your fucking head is you sat there,
you walked in,
right when you were like,
Hey Clem,
he,
oh yeah,
yeah.
Gimme all of them.
Give me a scope every there.
I want to pay your fucking mortgage tonight by order in three scoops of fucking
but your mortgage for the month.
I own three scoops of fucking ice cream.
That Ali,
one banana split and half sticking on both sides.
Like a banana fucking ice cream sandwich.
Oh,
doesn't that sound delicious?
I'm hallucinate.
None.
[inaudible] this is July 5th they haven't any chips,
any fucking ice cream.
No cookies,
no cake,
no fucking fast food,
no nothing.
And I'm a great shape.
And you know what?
I'm bored.
I miss the highs of sugar,
the lows of the salt coming back down.
All right?
We want to thank you for flying.
We know you have a lot of choices out there,
right?
You just fucking shoving the Saltin after you go.
You went through the stratosphere with the sugar.
Get too high.
Like fucking chuck Yeager when he do that.
How you open up a fucking bag of Jacks?
You stick that Orange Shit right down your fucking throat.
Don't you come on in for a landing
people please refrain from standing up.
Um,
I don't even know what the fuck I'm talking about either.
Don't feel lost.
All right?
So anyways,
my way in today.
All right.
And I needed to be one 74 [inaudible] 74 and I weighed in at one 73.6.
All freckles is fucking killing it.
I've lost 13 pounds on the nose.
Dan Marino number can Lisman number 13.
Okay,
I don't,
what else was number 13?
Whatever.
There's two people,
um,
13 fucking pounds,
13 pounds,
and I'm actually a finally,
people are starting to go,
hey,
you losing weight.
That's how fucking fat I was.
I lose 13 pounds just to kind of be out of shape.
You know?
My man titties are going away.
You know,
I got a little belly,
you know what I mean?
Like,
yeah,
you have to have like a,
like a fucking ever see a rack now or a raccoon or a squirrel goes out and eats
a whole pumpkin that sits there with his fucking belly.
All the standard.
That's what I look right now.
I look like a fucking squirrel.
Eight a pocket.
And you're like,
Bill,
why did you come up with that?
Because I saw it.
I fucking saw a squirrel after it did it and it was fucking sitting there.
The big distended,
I get like a trucker belly,
but it was adorable.
That's the kind of stomach I have right now.
Um,
so anyways,
not Jesus Christ.
I got to know what I want.
I gotta do.
I got another one.
It was my goal.
One 62.
I'm going down low this time.
I'm getting fucking skinny then and build them back up with the muscle,
right then I'm coming back on the booze and I figured by the end of the year it
can be over two bills as good for your heart.
Um,
whenever I'm psyched to have you back down to this God damn weight I feel,
but I am in,
I am in a,
I remember I was telling you guys like the different shape.
There's a with a jacket on in shape,
right?
Jacket off and shape.
Buttoned down shirt shape a button down,
tucked in shape.
Okay.
I sport coat in there somewhere.
There's a sport coat.
Half the jacket is a sport coat.
Then there's a button down shape.
Then there's t shirt on tuck shape.
That's why I'm at.
Then there's tucked in t shirt,
then there's no t shirt and then the granddaddy of them all sitting down,
no shirt on.
Still have a flat stomach.
The only thing you have is those little fucking wrinkles because you know,
if you actually reach up to get some cereals,
you don't want the skin to tear.
You need like you need it for when you reach
anyways.
Any fucking waste.
Uh,
all right,
so what should I talk about next?
Oh,
okay.
Rest in peace.
Frank Gifford,
man,
I'm actually really sad about that.
I'm not even gonna lie to you,
man.
That guy was a,
he was the fucking man.
He has such a great voice.
I mean he was part of basically,
he can't say he replaced Keith Jackson.
He replaced him on Monday night football and Keith Jackson,
Dandy,
Don Meredith and Howard Cosell.
There's never been a better announcing team,
at least in football as far as I'm concerned.
And I just remember being as a little kid when my dad would actually let me stay
up and watch,
at least the first quarter came on at nine o'clock at night.
So I get to stay up till like nine 39 40 when they would start that Shell and
Frank Gifford would,
I mean Howard Cosell would be doing the highlights.
That's why I got that thing when I was still doing the draft kings thing because
of that man right there.
I rent an old James Simpson,
right.
And he gets you all fucking amped up for the fucking game.
And then they immediately come back with Frank Gifford,
who just had the best fucking voice ever.
And then Dandy dawn would sing a song.
It was just,
it was the best man.
It was the best.
They always seem like they went out,
got some drinks afterwards.
It's just,
um,
the,
who's kidding,
who,
the kind of men that hipsters have been making fun of relentlessly and nerds
have made fun of for whatever,
just basically the guy's guy for one or for whatever reason the guy's guy is,
uh,
I dunno,
I guess cause most writers are nerds,
so they resent the guy's guy.
Cause when they walk into the room,
they've never held court.
I guess.
I don't know what it is,
not saying I'm a guy's guy,
but I would fucking love to hang out with those guys and I would shut the fuck
up when they told stories,
you know,
I dunno.
It just seems like every fucking commercial now is if there's a guy in it,
right,
if he's not being a complete moron with some woman rolling her fucking eyes,
it's always like some guy out in the woods and he's like,
fucking,
uh,
you know,
got a bear and a headlock and chopping down a tree with his foot.
Just this overly ridiculously manly shit.
Yeah.
It's annoying it to me that some do aspire to,
to be an outdoorsman.
You know,
it'd be out there in the woods,
see something big and furry and fucking take it out.
You know,
like that dentist did when he went over to Africa.
I mean,
say what you will.
It takes a lot of balls to smuggle a fucking lion's head out of,
out of Africa,
doesn't it?
As a dentist of fuck do you get off doing some CIA shit like that.
He just got done doing a fucking composite on Friday.
A Monday.
You're coming back with a lion's head.
It's incredible.
I don't,
I don't condone it.
I'm a big fan of fucking animals,
which is why,
you know,
at the end of the day with all these electromagnetic fields taken a bunch of
people out in the future,
that really doesn't bug me.
You know,
it doesn't bug me.
We got it.
It's time for us to go it alone.
At least like thin the herd,
right?
Maybe these corporations are doing a good thing.
They're fucking,
they're,
they're making like a,
uh,
corporation raid,
you know,
kills bugs dead.
Maybe go punch in.
Oh my God.
Can imagine the fucking nerds that are going to be dropping,
you know,
full amount of fucking nerds that are going to die and then Jesus Christ.
Then what are we going to do?
No.
Back to the fucking stone age.
You need nerds.
Just like you need the guy's guy,
right?
You got to have somebody out there doing extra manly.
So you know what kills me is the amount of people that are making fun of Frank
Gifford had one fucking affair.
You know,
if he had more than that,
fuck you.
You walk a day in his fucking cleats being the star fucking halfback.
You know the New York giants,
He played in the greatest game ever played against the fucking cold.
She won a championship.
You played for USC,
you know?
Yeah.
High School football team.
I mean football stadium in Bakersfield,
California is named after you.
Let's see.
You handle that fucking those beautiful women throwing themselves at you.
You know,
Catholic Lee's giving you shit about where you're putting your shoes and all of
that.
Then you go out and there she is bad.
No fucking Isaiah.
Yeah.
You know,
you walk a day in those fucking,
you fucking don't do anything.
Then you could judge frank until then.
You shut your fucking ringless championship fingers.
Gfe Cif,
ring less fingers.
I think that that's how I'm supposed to say.
Um,
anyways.
Yeah,
so that's it.
They're all gone.
Keith Jackson is the last one and this is all making me feel very,
very fucking old.
This whole changing of the guard man,
all of these guys,
Vin Scully,
Keith Jackson,
Frank Gifford,
how cause sell all these guys,
you know,
as these new guys,
he's snarky fucking cons.
Who come in and sit there taking the piss out of the fucking athletes,
that ESPN thing,
which was kind of funny at first when they made the highlights.
Kind of funny,
but I don't know.
I don't like it.
Now
you're a nerd.
It's why you're behind a desk.
That guy's an athlete and he's better than you and you won his life.
Quit taking pot shots at him when he's not around.
And I could say that because I never take pot shots on athletes.
Okay.
On this podcast.
Yes I do.
I've done it all the fucking,
I'm a fucking hypocrite.
What do you want from me?
What Bell?
We'd like a quality podcast every once in a while.
Oh,
would you stop with the hurtful shit?
All right.
What am I doing?
Hell,
it's,
let's read some advertising here.
See how long these people last?
Um,
all right,
well,
we got a new advertiser this week.
Well,
God knows some slots have opened up.
All right,
trunk club.
Everybody
has officially arrived.
Well,
yeah,
it's August.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
These people,
they've,
they write copy once and that means you're too busy firing up the grill and
sunning in the sand.
Even think about setting foot in a mall.
The problem is you still need to look fresh.
All snap trunk club gets it.
That's why they've taken the hassle man out of shopping by shipping you a trunk
full of clothes that fit perfectly and make you look like 1 million bucks or at
least a hundred grant.
That's a lot more money than any of friends have unless do dads
areRich@trunkclub.com slash burr.
You answer simple questions about your style,
your preferences,
and size it,
and then they are yours.
You're assigned an expert stylist
who handpicks close,
curated from the best premium brands that are perfect for you.
You pick what you like and just like that,
a trunk full of clothes,
Hanford close arrives at your door.
You only pay for the clothes you keep.
No ongoing subscriptions,
no hidden charges,
just great closes and right now closes close and right now their services
completely free.
In other words,
rolled into all of this other bullshit.
Get started@trunkclub.com slash bird that's trunk club at slack.com/burr start
the summer off right with trunk club.
One more time.
Hi,
trunk club.com/bar all right,
let's blow through these this week.
What do we say how people,
I only got two more.
All right is the newbies,
the newbies on the block,
fresh fish,
a next issue.
Oh our friends here at next issue.
Your time is precious and you want to feed your mind with the best of what's out
there,
but who has time to sift through all the nonsense on the Internet?
Hey,
I'm on the Internet.
My podcast is all he call my podcast,
call it nonsense.
Uh,
for those of us who want premium content and don't have time to waste finding
it,
there's next issue.
Next issue is the mobile app that lets you tap directly into the world's most
popular magazines.
Anytime,
anywhere using your phone or tablet,
they got all your favorites like sports illustrated and Maxim and Esquire and
next issue lets you dive deeper into the story with interactive content not
available anywhere else.
Well,
what are you going to interact with?
Could you smell the person there that's creepy giving you a rich sharing or
richer reading experience?
The best part,
next issue is offering a free trial right now.
When you go to next issue.com/ [inaudible] sign up for next issue.
Right now you'll get immediate access to all the top magazines including back
issues and exclusive videos and photos.
That's pretty cool.
Again,
you can try next issue for free right now when you go to next issue.com/burr and
lastly,
but certainly not leastly stamps.com there,
there's gotta be a better way to mail and ship stuff.
Going to the post office takes up way too much time.
Leasing a postage meter sucks and it's way too expensive.
Turns out,
guess what?
There's a way better way stamps.com with stamps.com you can buy and print
official US postage,
not counterfeit official US postage for any letter or package right from your
desk using your own computer and Britta even get special posted discounts.
She can't find it.
The post office plus stamps.com is more powerful than a postage meter at just a
fraction of the cost.
You can save at least 50% compared to the postage meter and you'll avoid all
those time consuming trips to the post office and you won't have to smell some
old woman's hair.
I use stamps.com domain a lot.
All my posters,
whenever I'm whoring myself out after shows right now,
use my last name.
Birth for this special offer,
four week trial plus a hundred $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale
and up to $55 free postage.
Do not wait.
Go to stamps.com before you
do anything else,
click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinabirdthatstampsdotcomenterbirthstamps.com.
That's it for hi stamps.com comment to burp.
All right there we did it.
We got through it.
It's over.
Um,
so anyways,
oh,
you know what,
I get finally fucking gave it to uh,
Jimmy Page for like the 50th time since John Bonam has died,
has figured out a new way to repackage the same fucking 10 11 albums that they
made.
And I bought all of them every fucking time.
And this time I was like,
you know what?
Fuck you Jimmy page.
I'm done.
I'm done with you coming up with the same bag of fucking goods and it just
putting a different fucking rapper on it.
And then,
you know,
we'll still never received phone,
never before seen photos at all of that shit.
Um,
so I ignored the first one.
I ignored the second one and now the final one came out,
led Zepplin presence,
led Zeppelin in through the outdoor and led Zepplin Coda.
And I guess the Cota one has been getting some rave reviews.
So I finally said fuck it.
And I went down and I bought all three of them,
but I didn't buy the boxing that came with a booklet.
Listen,
never seen before photos,
but 99% of them have already fucking scene,
you know.
And uh,
I haven't had a listen to it yet,
but I went down,
I bought those.
I didn't get,
I didn't get the whole big fucking thing with the cds and all of that.
God Damn Horse Shit.
Um,
and Jimmy promises,
this is the last time that he's going to repackage this shit.
And uh,
I did pretty good this time.
I only bought,
yeah,
I only bought like one,
one issue of it.
I know they didn't,
one of them,
they won't like the very,
you know,
the,
that hey,
hey,
what can you do?
Like it's still obscure.
It's like he can listen to that whenever you want on the Internet.
And it's also you fucking release that on some box set.
I remember in the 90s,
the one that had the fucking shadow of the Zeppelin over the cornfields.
Right?
Isn't that what happened?
I don't fucking know.
I Dunno.
But um,
I've been playing drums like a fucking maniac and I've been taking lessons
trying to work on my technique and it turns out I was doing everything wrong.
So literally today I'm learning how to hit a fucking snare drum,
something I've done probably 100,000 times in my life thinking I was doing it
correctly.
And um,
anybody who plays drums,
if you ever get a chance to just break down everything that you do,
it's fucking amazing.
MMM.
This teacher I have and he's showing me all this stuff where,
uh,
just even like where I was hitting the shaft of the stick on the high hat,
I was hitting it where it was starting to taper so I wasn't getting,
it was getting more of a tinny sound and he had me move it up.
That was night and day,
the molar method of,
of just my arm,
totally fucking relaxed,
getting a better sound.
And then today he was showing me something,
I was playing something on the bellow this symbol.
And because of the way I was holding the stick,
like whenever I hit the bell and you could hear the bell,
but it never sounded good.
But now because I wasn't choking the shit out of this stick.
Yeah.
Like the stick has a different sound and it makes a different noise.
It makes it more like,
it's like a brighter,
it was like I was chair,
I was choking on the stick,
which was choking off the sound of the symbol,
all the drums and all of that type of thing.
And I would get fucking blisters and shit.
Um,
and I always say,
oh,
I haven't played in a while.
So I got blistered.
It's like,
no,
you're dope.
You're holding it fucking stick wrong.
So,
um,
okay.
I Dunno.
So I'm going to just,
just do that like 15 times a day.
It's so it'd be like if she drove a car for 20 fucking years and all of a sudden
somebody showed you a different way to drive a car and if you want,
but if you,
as you got behind the wheel,
be totally uncomfortable and you couldn't drive it as well as you could.
And the temptations just go back to the other fucking way is a,
is,
is the,
is the biggest battle out of all of it.
But,
uh,
I am going to,
I'm going to stick with it and,
uh,
as I,
as I do as Shit,
you know,
I tried to stick with shit once they start to learn,
speaking to that man,
I think,
uh,
all my shit's gonna come this week for me,
for the big green egg and I'm finally going to try and smoke something,
fuck it up,
and then fix it.
So I'm going to get the smallest pork shoulder.
Maybe we'll just get some ribs and I'll try smoking those fucking things.
Just see if I can actually get a,
a,
uh,
so I'm able to keep it at,
at a,
at a certain temperature.
I don't,
I still don't get how you fucking do it.
I've watched all these goddamn youtube videos actually was on PBS today watching
a barbecue show.
Uh,
by the way,
PBS,
unbelievably underrated.
PBS.
It's like you watch something and then they show upcoming programs.
It's like,
I want to watch all of that.
That all seems cool.
So,
um,
anyways,
but you know,
something,
let's,
I'm all over the fucking map today.
Speaking of Frank Gifford,
which I was like 20 God damn minutes ago.
Um,
okay.
Football season.
Okay.
How far away is it now?
It starts in the second week of September.
Is that what the fuck it is?
I have no idea.
All I know is Tom Brady comes back in the fifth week.
Nice and rested nice and pissed off.
So I'm fucking excited about that.
I know college football starts,
I think like the first week,
maybe of September.
Um,
I was sitting there fucking looking for something to watch today.
I watched,
uh,
a couple seconds of the wn Ba and I was like,
all right,
let me find a baseball game,
which I couldn't find.
Yeah,
cause I don't have the MLB package.
Um,
so there was no game on when I turned it on.
So then I,
I watched a whole thing on that,
that,
that 13 year old girl that pitched to the little league world,
watch something on her,
then went back to the w NBA and then there's just next thing you know,
I'm watching like a fucking how to smoke meat on PBS because there's absolutely
nothing going on.
Maybe that's why they're doing all this Tom Brady Shit.
It's just like completely fucking a slow news day.
Nobody knows what the,
you know,
like,
what do you do
fucking,
I,
I'm like the amount of,
I that's my best when I'm doing all this shit.
Learn how to play drums,
taking the fucking,
uh,
autorotation class,
all of that shit.
I'm getting those things down.
Everybody.
The one 80 autos,
get it done.
I,
you guys don't give a fuck about any of this.
Let me,
uh,
here's something for you.
I bought those fucking Zeplin things on,
on vinyl.
And I want to tell you guys that the reason why I buy vinyl is because I just
think it looks cool.
It's a nice big,
actually see what the album cover looks like.
You can hold it in your hand,
you know?
Okay.
It doesn't,
you know,
all of a sudden have a little cloud next to it and then I got to buy it again or
something crashes.
I liked that,
but I'm,
I'm going to be the first to tell you I cannot tell the difference even remotely
between vinyl,
a cassette tape,
a CD,
or fucking digital.
I have no idea what little Steven is talking about and all these fucking rock
stars at a scene that I am not going to be that guy that goes,
it sounds better.
Huh?
Can,
can you hear that?
Can you hear that Bass Drum pedal?
That sounds the exact fucking same to me.
Okay.
Same thing with all those reissued guitars is a reissued 1959 Les Paul.
Here's a real one.
You hear the difference?
No Sir.
Not at all.
That's probably cause I have shitty years,
which you know what?
There's a bliss in that.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's how I can drive a Prius.
Okay.
I drove a Goddamn 2008 Prius in traffic right next to a fucking lamp.
Gainey today the dead.
You know what the fuck's he going,
dude,
you have a,
if you drive a Lamborghini down the street,
you are a fucking jerk off.
The only time that car should be on the street is if it's driving up to a ramp
to be loaded onto a truck to then be taken to the track.
What kind of a fucking asshole?
I guess you drive around and just women fucking drop their panties.
I guess that's why you do it,
you know?
But then by all means,
don't date.
Don't date some woman that just runs up to your Lamborghini.
He can't fucking date that.
You can't.
What you gotta do is you've got to drive around like a fucking Ford escort
station wagon.
Right.
And then start hitting on women,
you know?
Well,
let me ask too,
that's too much.
That's too much of a test.
What kind of fuck a woman wants that,
you know,
they're allowed to have standards,
you know?
Oh,
are we built?
Thank you.
Yeah.
I'd say drive around in a fucking,
uh,
late model.
Uh,
maybe a Nissan leaf
just drive around.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that'd be a fucking interesting,
like fucking prank shell.
If you let a guy,
he pulls up in a Nissan leaf and he fucking hits on some chick,
right?
She tells him to fuck off and he drives away in his fucking electric car.
They drives around the Coney,
puts on a fake mustache and a hat and now he's in a Lamborghini just to see that
her different fucking attitude.
But is that really fair?
That's not fair,
is it?
Yeah.
Why wouldn't a woman want to talk to a guy in a Lamborghini?
What is she supposed to do?
You know?
Well,
woman lays in beds going,
you know what?
Someday I'm going to meet my prince charming and he's going to pull up in a
Nissan leaf.
They don't think that,
do they?
I Dunno what they think.
Why would I talk for them?
Do you think Katelyn knows what they think now or Bruce now knows?
Cause now he's Caitlyn.
You ever think about that?
Okay.
Do you think Katelyn looks in the mirror every once in awhile
and talks to Bruce.
Okay.
I can't,
I can't imagine what that must be like.
You know what I mean?
Cause if you wanted to do that right now,
you've freed yourself,
but then you know what I mean?
Don't you miss the other person a little bit.
Yeah.
Then you have all his fucking memories.
You'd like fucking Robo Cop.
You know,
you
start having like flashbacks and shit.
I Dunno.
I don't fucking know.
All I know is I wish Bruce gave a farewell.
That would have been awesome.
You know what I mean?
Eh.
Great.
Thai be and Bruce sold a lot of ways.
Yeah.
One that decathlon,
I was on chips,
right?
Very great town with all you guys.
I bought a day Ghalia being there for me.
Is it?
This is a living wake
for fucking Bruce Jenner and then he just walks off.
You get to give them one more standing ovation.
I think that's what fucks me up.
But I didn't get a chance to say goodbye.
No.
Which happens when somebody fucking dies.
We didn't die.
He just became Caitlyn.
I got to meet her to see if I can just be like,
Katelyn,
do you mind if I asked Bruce a question?
What can I ask a Bruce question?
How do I phrase this without getting in trouble with you?
MMM.
Glancing down at a feet,
you know,
see if he can fucking see all those years of running track and field down there.
You know,
I think Katelyn goes with a closed toe shoe when you,
okay.
Probably his hammer toes.
You can't do all those events without him fucked up feet.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
Jesus Christ,
if you danced in
wicked for fun or rage stage for fucking five seasons,
you're feeding and be fucked up for life.
And that's a God damn musical.
This guy,
this guy want to,
why don't you want to fuck a decathlon?
Okay,
Jesus Christ.
There's got to be some fucked up.
Fucking,
we just got the most fucked up feet.
Basketball players,
tennis players.
Oh,
by the way,
I'm reading this Andre Agassi,
a autobiography that somebody gave me.
Man,
it's fucking unbelievable.
Jesus Christ.
I'm only like,
like the first 60 pages.
He ain't one of those dads that just decided that,
that it's like,
hey,
guess what you're doing?
You're going to be the number one tennis player in the world and you're sitting
there like,
I just want to play with my legos.
And he's like,
shut the fuck up and get outside.
I built you a tennis court and then you go out there and you just do that every
fucking day and you don't want to do it.
It's unbelievable.
What fucking kills me is he didn't want to do it and any still won Wimbledon.
He still won the US Open.
Did he win the French?
I'm not sure.
Did He,
did he get the career Grand Slam?
Oh,
I think that's time to look it up.
Let's put this apple computer that might be fucking radiate my nuts right now.
All right,
hang on a second.
I actually thought for half a second that if I did get it,
at least I'd get a flat fucking stomach.
How obsessed in my with this shit.
All right,
Andre Agassi crushed me when I found out I was fucking two years old.
Oh look at that.
The Internet doesn't work in here.
Isn't that fucking wonderful?
Jesus fucking Christ.
Um,
I give up with the shit.
Do you know today I want to use the calculator on my phone and I don't know what
button I hit.
It just fucking kept doubling the number and I couldn't get it to stop and I
kept hitting clear and I finally,
I just set the fucking thing down.
I went over,
I got a fucking pencil and a pen,
a pen,
I'm sorry.
And a pad of paper and I just worked it out the old fucking way.
And you know what?
My,
my brain and my hand will never be obsolete till I die.
Right then who gives a fuck as I'm dead,
you know?
No,
it's upgraded and I'll get the new one right.
That weird.
Everything about that.
Your hands,
the same fucking hand that you've been jerking off with since you figured out
how to do it then unreal.
You ever think about that?
You bought it on my fucking hand is 47 fucking years old.
You think in the future you can just get like new shit.
You know what I mean?
Like on your car,
how you start,
it goes after a while,
then you've got to get a new starter and you fuck as a car will last forever if
you just keep replacing the parts.
I think that that's what they're working on doing,
you know?
But God knows that won't be available to us if they ever figured out how to
fucking do that.
Right.
They keep it for themselves.
This is where the conspiracy theory guy comes in if they don't have that
already.
Um,
but they would keep that shift for themselves.
Right.
And they just keep fucking,
you know,
unscrewing and then re screwing a new fucking head on their body like a goddamn
light bulb,
you know?
Then in the future you can pick out different heads,
like,
what do you want to look like?
You know what I mean?
You can just try out everything
you want to be looking like a Schlub,
but you could be like every fucking race,
every hairstyle.
You know,
you just keep putting your brain in there and be like getting a new fucking car
every couple of years.
Who doesn't want to do that?
Would you do it?
Would you just ride it out?
But anyways,
I think that that they're going to fucking,
they gonna have it right now cause they're you there.
You can grow like a fucking ear in a petri dish.
Right.
They could do that for years.
Then all of a sudden they stopped talking about it.
They grow ear and a fucking petri dish and then all of a sudden there was no
more talk about it.
You eat all those fuckers didn't stop with,
I bet they could do the whole head now.
Okay.
Think about it,
man.
What a Dick Cheney GFE he's got all those problems with his heart,
right?
Where the fuck did he go?
I bet he's off somewhere getting a new fucking heart,
getting a new ticker.
You know what I mean?
Like a new crate motor came in the other day when that'd be fucking awesome.
Then you just keep going.
You know what it is is
the temptation to sell that to the masses.
You know all the fucking money that he could make.
Cause that's what the fuck they were in to right data.
Eventually you have to do it and then they would give us,
you know,
we wouldn't get as good as fucking the hedge is.
They got,
it'd be like whiskey.
They be drinking like Scotch,
like top shelf fucking shit.
And we would just get like,
you know the bud light a heads,
you know,
keystone light,
fucking heart hands or some shit.
And that would be like,
that'll be,
that's going to be the goal in the future to make enough money that you can
actually,
you know,
when you get your replacement head you can actually get a good one,
like a decent look in one,
you know?
Yeah.
You go out,
you fucking get a get a deal or some shit.
You come and just some money,
your parents can be like,
all right,
I don't go out there and blow it all on her head.
Shaved some for feet and hands in the future.
Well,
mom,
if I have a better head,
I can get a better broad.
Okay?
I you don't need it do that.
You just save up money and you buy the broad,
you're with a better head.
She loves you for who you are,
Blah.
You there?
Can you see that?
The future I kid.
Oh,
I see a future where heads will be sold.
Where do they get their heads while they grow up?
Then they'll have like bootleg heads you off to get lucky.
Gheybi you got to have like your own fucking head farm.
You gotta be like,
it's gotta be like sanctioned by the government,
regulated and all that shit at Tarzana today I'll raid on a bootleg head farm,
right?
And then a big fucking greenhouse with a bunch of heads in there and everybody
running out.
Um,
then Denzel plays the fucking greatest fucking bootleg head dealer ever.
You know,
kick off,
right?
He's got a bunch of fucking heads buying.
Yeah.
Right.
And everybody's like,
well,
that fucking movies,
just like his other movies just with heads.
Oh yeah.
Well,
you fucking right.
One,
you can't.
Um,
I right.
What the fuck up to,
how many minutes is it?
I'm just trying to fill time.
You know,
it gives a shit.
I'm all right.
By the way,
everybody,
if you'd like to donate to this podcast,
um,
here's an easy way to do it that won't cost you any fucking money.
Next time you go on to Amazon,
just go to bill,
go to my website first,
click on the podcast page,
and then click on the Amazon link.
Then you're on Amazon.
No fucking big deal.
All right.
And then they kick money back to me for driving traffic there.
It doesn't cost you any money.
10% of the money I kicked back to Saint Jude.
In fact,
I owe those fuckers a check this week.
Um,
you know,
I actually,
when I buy shit on Amazon,
I go through my website.
What a cheap prick her.
I would go with that old guy.
Oh,
penny pincher.
Um,
anyways,
so if you would like to,
uh,
send an email into this podcast,
it's bill@themmpodcast.com.
All right,
bill@themmpodcast.com.
That's where you send the shit a poster information.
If listeners who ordered a southern tour poster,
it have not received it yet,
they should email bill burr,
merge@gmail.com include the name,
address,
order number,
Boston tour posters will arrive within the next 10 to 14 days if they haven't
already.
All right.
I know what kind of slow at the posters,
but everybody else was like,
hey,
we'll send out your posters and we're going to take 90% of the profit.
So
I kind of doing it in house here so you know,
cut me some fucking slacker.
Right?
And if you really can't wait,
I'll refund your God damn money.
All right,
relax.
It's just a fucking poster.
MMM.
Oh,
by the way,
I have a big announcement.
I'm pregnant now then I'm making,
I'm making today.
Um,
as of Monday,
August 10th at 9:00 PM tonight,
9:00 PM tonight.
Um,
tickets go sale.
I'm doing Madison Square Garden if you can believe it.
Oh,
Billy fucking red cakes is playing Madison Square Garden on Saturday,
November 14th.
MMM.
I'll have,
I'll tweet out all this shit.
I don't have the information right now.
They're gonna send it to me tomorrow morning,
which is your morning right now.
So I'll have already tweeted it out.
And the uh,
the presale is going to be tomorrow starting at 9:00 PM east coast time and the
presale code is all you do is you type in Larry Legend 33.
Yeah.
One more time for a unique fans out there.
Larry Legend 33.
Uh,
I'm playing Madison Square Garden and a,
they asked me if I wanted to name the show and I was like,
of course.
And there's only one thing I could name it.
Come on.
I'm doing stand up and Madison Square Garden.
Okay.
Led Zeppelin shot the song remains the same in that building.
What do I name my special?
Yeah,
come on.
Thank you.
Does anybody remember laughter?
Do you remember that Robert Plant said that he gets so much shit for saying that
he sees said that uh,
during the,
uh,
stairway to heaven,
right?
He's like in the four is will echo with laughter.
Does anybody,
everybody shit on him because it was very topical.
They shot that in like 73 or 74.
So the Vietnam War was winding down in the last 10 years.
Anybody with the vision was shot and killed by alone,
crazed gunman,
both Kennedys,
Martin Luther King,
Malcolm x,
Medgar Evers,
all these fucking great people got whacked.
And I was aware of Watergate was going on in the fucking gas prices were going
up through the fucking roof or petrol is the fucking English people say it has
all the,
that was a legitimate question in 1973.
Yeah.
Does anybody remember?
Laughter?
Uh,
but then,
you know,
the 80s came and everybody was on coke do it.
What the fuck is this guy talking about?
I'm laughing all the way to the bank,
bud.
Fox greed is good.
So yeah,
so that's the name of the show.
Does anybody remember laughter?
And I liked it because led Zeppelin fans will get it.
And I also like it because people who drive by,
it'll look like the most arrogant thing ever.
Like I'm saying,
I'm the greatest comedian ever,
and none of these other comics that making you laugh.
Um,
so
yeah,
so that's happening.
So I'm doing that and uh,
I already know what I'm going to do if they let me,
if they let me,
I'm going to rent a drum kit and I'm going to bring it into that building.
And during the day when it's completely empty,
I'm going to fucking in my fucking iPhone and I'm going to,
I'm going to play
okay
to all my fucking Zeppelin,
shit,
Motley Crue,
all that shit that I came up with.
And then before the show starts,
I'm removing the drum kit because I would never make you sit through that
during the day.
I'm going to have a good fucking time.
Uh,
me and Paul Versey are going to be,
uh,
doing it.
I might add somebody else.
I'm not sure yet,
but as of right now,
it's being Paul Versey and uh,
okay.
Paul's fucking hilarious.
He was all excited about,
you know,
cause he had biggest nick nicks fan ever.
MMM.
And he said to me,
he goes,
dude,
you know what's funny?
He goes,
I already know what my opening jokes going to be.
He knows it in August.
That's how much of a fuck I'm just going to say.
Somehow it has to be about the Knicks is what I'm guessing.
Um,
so anyways,
let's get into the,
uh,
the questions here by the way,
that it's an unbelievable,
I can't believe I'm going to get to do that and I want to thank everybody who's
come out to my shows over the years and spread the word a about my shit.
Um,
so I get to do that fucking thing.
So that's a major,
that's not even a bucket list thing.
That's not something I even ever even thought of ever doing.
Um,
there's a couple that I want to do that I really want to do.
okay.
Is A,
I want to do Royal Albert Hall at some point in England.
I got to do that one cause that's another place that Zeppelin played.
Although that place really seems like a tight ass place and would not let me
bring a set of drums in during the day.
But you never know.
They might,
you know,
who knows.
Um,
anyways.
Uh,
alright.
Frank Gifford,
everybody.
This is the first question,
Bill.
I'm not sure if you're going to talk about frank Giffords passing.
Do you have a favorite Monday night football involving Gifford?
Yes.
Every one that he ever did.
MMM.
And of course the person talks about,
you know,
all the women that he bagged and shipped,
which is really a nerd thing to do.
You know,
don't pick up,
let me,
what are you gonna do it?
You fucked a couple of stewardesses.
Who gives a shit?
So what are you,
you know,
you had all these great accomplishments.
You know that the fucking guy down at home depot can keep his dick in his pants.
Frank,
if it's supposed to be a saint.
The guy lived element in almost every decade.
I think he did a pretty good fucking job,
you know?
Okay.
It God can't get mad at him if there's a god.
God,
she just be throwing his hands up.
Well,
that's what I get for making a guy that good.
This is fucking great hair and be in the halfback playing in New York,
Heisman trophy winner,
Jesus Christ.
That's what I made beautiful women for,
for guys like this to go out and fuck.
Um,
the,
the God in my head,
that's how we talks.
You know,
he doesn't get mad.
Do you think he really gets mad?
Like what a Hitler comes on?
He doesn't like look at himself like,
Ooh,
fucked up on that one.
I must have made that one on Sunday when I was half asleep.
All right.
National Book Day,
everybody.
I'm actually getting back to that Frank Gifford thing.
Like,
okay.
Those guys were,
were just Frank Gifford,
Don Meredith and Howard Cosell.
Those guys were absolute gods to me.
Brian Gumbel,
uh,
Bob Costas,
Al Michaels,
um,
Keith Jackson.
You know,
just all those guys.
I Love Bryant Gumbel and uh,
Mike Adam Lee,
when they used to do NFL 81,
NFL 80 and all that shit,
they will fucking amazing.
MMM.
I just grew up on all of those guys.
And sportswear.
I Dunno,
it was just,
it was just different back then.
Sports was this small fucking thing of just sports fans.
You know what I mean?
Like the Beatles didn't play halftime at the fucking super bowl.
They just had a high school,
God damn band went out there.
You know,
this,
you know,
the first two Superbowls,
they weren't called soup bowls.
They were just called the AFL NFL NFL NFL championship game.
And do you know neither one of them sold out?
Okay.
It's fucking unreal.
Like that's how small it was.
And he used to watch,
I used to watch the local news every fucking night.
He used to watch a WBZ NBC W uh,
the Wbz channel,
which was the NBC affiliate.
Yeah.
Jack Williams,
who just retired was as Liz Walker,
Bob Lowe Bell
and uh,
Bob Labella do sports.
It was like six,
seven minutes.
That was it.
He had to go around the whole fucking league.
And if you really wanted to see baseball highlights from around the league,
you would watch this week in baseball or football,
you'd watch inside the NFL on Hbo.
And that came out.
That was fucking unreal because all the,
anything else you had to do,
you had to wait for NFL films to come up with something.
So it's totally changed.
So those guys were bigger than life.
Who is the guy used to be on ABC's wide world of sports.
Okay.
God dammit.
I was into everything.
Jackie Stewart,
when he would do the formula one racing here,
that Scottish accent I thought was so fucking cool.
Um,
then Scully,
of course.
Um,
and then you had all the local guys and back then you had all those Homer's.
I,
you know,
I hate sports fans that can't stand.
Homer announces there's nothing better than a fucking homer announcer says the
greatest.
Do you know,
there was a guy used to do the Bruins in between periods and he grew a beard and
he wouldn't in,
and he wasn't going to shave it off until we won the cup.
Sky had a fucking beard,
my whole God damn life.
And I remember when they want it.
In 2011,
I went on the Internet,
tried to find the guy to see if he finally fucking shaved it off.
MMM.
So,
uh,
yeah,
these guys,
you guys who are young,
you'll see it someday.
The people that you loved when you were a kid.
When they get old and they pass away,
it dead.
Kidney had fucking makes you really sad.
But then also there's also the thing like,
man,
a couple more generations and then it's my turn.
It
uh,
whatever the fuck I'm having a great life.
And if I died tomorrow,
I had a great time.
I had a great one.
I did all right.
National Book Day.
Dear Billy Shakespeare,
of course I use that one today.
Sunday is a national book day.
Uh,
you have an updated us on what you're reading and quite some time any
recommendations.
Yes,
I'm reading a,
the Andre Agassi a biography,
which I think is called open and a tremendous,
and the reason why I also haven't been updating you on anything that had been
readings cause I don't read that much.
Um,
I tell you my wife bought that,
uh,
she bought that Kim Kardashian Book of nothing but selfies.
Like she's really into like pop culture.
Oh,
we had that argument about it.
I'm still seeing that book over by the phone.
Then I always have to turn it over.
I always have to turn the fucking thing over.
I just can't,
there's just,
you want me to just walk by and you watch some girl like,
you know,
doing that.
Will they hold the camera up and they're trying to adjust their fucking heads,
you know,
to try to look better looking or this is this,
this angle right here is the way I look the best.
You know,
somebody should make a fucking,
there's gotta be a thread of just videos of people fucking doing that shit.
Does it bill,
does it have to be something like that?
He had to be such a crabby old content.
Um,
yeah,
that's what I'm reading right now.
I'm reading a,
the Andre Agassi,
uh,
open.
That's what I'm reading.
And uh,
it's tremendous.
And I like reading autobiographies by people that did great things,
which is such a stupid thing to say because,
you know,
they just have some regular guy.
That would be an interesting autobiography if you just never fucking strived for
anything.
You know,
we just did is you just did the bare fucking minimum.
He lived in a one bedroom apartment.
You always had like a six of fucking Miller high life,
you know,
some deviled eggs in there.
That was it.
You sat there and listen to baseball games on the radio and he just stared out
the fucking window.
You know,
there is something to be said about that.
You're not hurting anybody,
you know.
Anyways,
you know what,
I got to find out the name,
you know,
that time a long time ago.
I mean,
uh,
Bobby Kelly and Joe de Rosa made that short film cheap.
We were in,
we were in the Tribeca film festival and we did a,
and we were with this whole series of short films and this kid,
I've got to find out the name of his,
he made this great short film.
I'll find it out from de Rosa and I always say that I'm going to find out that I
never do,
but I'm going to have this time.
Um,
he made this great short film about he had an uncle or his grandfather is
something and uh,
he just didn't know anything them and he lived a life like that.
And when he died,
he found the guy's diary.
He kept a diary sort of,
and he was able to piece together this guy's fucking life.
And it was funny cause he was,
he didn't know the guy,
but it was a really funny,
mmm.
I want to say touching,
but I don't want to you guys to trash me.
But it was,
it was,
it moved you,
but it was really funny and I think you'll,
what the fuck was the guys in line?
His last words on his deathbed where that you said that's it.
And I remember saying to Derosa after we saw the film,
I go,
what do you think he meant by that?
And Joe said,
I don't know,
but I would give my left arm to know what he meant.
Like who says that's it?
Like,
you know,
you're going to die.
Like what?
What did he feel that he knew he was going to die in that moment?
I got now.
None.
I I fucking prime the pump here.
I got to get the name of that fucking thing.
Yeah.
You know I'm to do,
I'm going to stand my wallet up here on the table.
When I look at that,
I'll be like,
why did I stand it up there and then I'll fucking remember.
Cause if I don't,
you have to do shit like that.
I do.
I don't give a fuck if you don't.
Um,
all right,
Trump dear Billy elect.
I don't agree with everything Trump says,
but I wholeheartedly believe that he's the only person that can set this country
on a course of honesty.
I'd rather know what a guy is actually thinking and disagree then to not know
what he's thinking and to have to have faith.
What are your thoughts?
Um,
says phone store girl.
Uh,
on our,
sorry.
That's the next one.
Um,
I 100% agree.
That's why he,
even though he said all that stupid shit about Mexicans to just,
you know,
having a white like did take about that guide.
The shitty says about Mexicans and stuff like it's fucked up as it is.
It's like,
that's what a white guy who's lived on the top floor of a skyscraper.
That's,
that's the kind of shit that,
that's the way they think.
I would die.
Bender the border,
Huh?
Yeah.
Did you fucking drive by in your air conditioned to SUV for fucking 20 minutes.
You don't want you talking about,
I'm not trashing,
I'm not trashing the guy like took that fucking shitty said about the bankers
again.
I felt vindicated when he was going like when they were giving him shit for
declaring bankruptcy and he goes,
he goes,
I've done hundreds and hundreds of deals four times,
four times.
I've taken advantage of the bankruptcy laws by the way.
They are lies.
So he's not doing anything illegal.
And he goes,
and by the way,
let's not make out these people that loaned me money to be these innocent little
daisies or whatever goes.
They're not exactly innocent.
He goes,
these guys are killers and he's 100% right.
Hundred percent fucking right.
Having said all that,
I mean,
that money was also put in to the bags by mom and pop people,
but it was printed up by the bankers and it's really not our money.
It's their money and you're,
they give it to you and your job's to get into as much debt as humanly possible
without going under and paying those cons for the rest of your fucking life.
They are killers.
MMM.
But having said that,
there's,
there's no way
any one person could get this country in order because what would happen is if
he got elected,
he would threaten everybody else who got in the other way and no one would work
with him.
MMM.
In a childish way.
And then they would blame him.
And then the guys who put the money behind,
all the politicians also own newspapers and everyone would just smear Donald
Trump.
And then every fucking moron who thinks they know shit about politics would be
like,
so it doesn't work,
doesn't fucking work.
It'll go right back to the way that they wanted.
Um,
to truly change any government to truly fucking change.
When it's his corrupt is we are,
and most of the other governments,
I'm not just shitting on my country,
but as corrupt as we are.
The only way to do it is you have to have literally a revolution and people are
gonna die and people are going to go on trial and there's going to be fucking
firing squads and all that type of shit.
You know,
you don't just go like,
Hey,
we've had enough.
And then the people in power go,
oh,
okay.
Hi,
here's the keys to the castle.
Let's see how you do.
Can I have a job if it doesn't go down like that?
So,
um,
but I will say,
that guy,
he's a of Donald Trump is a fucking star.
Uh,
but I also liked,
there was a couple of the guys in the panel I liked,
I liked a ran Paul.
And then I liked the,
uh,
the oldest fella there.
What the fuck's his name?
I can't remember.
But that guy from Jersey is a fucking dope.
He's just smart enough to seem smart.
But at the end of the day,
a these big fucking roast beef head.
He's a,
he's a fucking dope.
That guy should not go beyond the state level,
but he will.
He will.
Um,
all right.
Phone store girl.
Okay.
All right.
Billy boy.
Last week my girlfriend lent her cell phone.
Oh,
what to you?
Okay.
Last week my girl lent her cell phone because mine,
Shit,
the bed.
You,
you missed a word there.
Lent me her cell phone.
Okay.
I borrowed a phone on the way to get,
oh Jesus.
Oh God.
Here we go.
I borrowed her phone and the way to get my new phone because I had some work
calls to make as it left the house.
I thought it was strange because it felt like,
because it felt like we would be breaking up soon.
I get to the place and a young cute chick is working there.
I ended up getting paired with her over the other miserable looking losers
working there.
Wow.
I thought this has got to go another direction.
I think he would say you went there and then she got some fucked up text.
All right,
here we go.
At one point I had to hand her my girlfriend's phone because I had taken a
picture of a number I needed to activate my new phone.
When the girl slid the picture slid the picture over by accident.
Yup.
You guessed it.
A picture of my girlfriend topless.
The girl's swipe back immediately and I just stood there.
I actually didn't even really react much,
just kind of took it all in.
She looked at me and goes,
good for you.
Oh Jesus.
This girl's a Gamer that broke the ice.
This girl was very cool.
Yeah.
Think we joked around before and after the end.
After this incident.
All right,
this is what you need to do.
Break up with this other girl immediately cause you already said you feel like
you're going to break up and get out.
Seem upset by it,
which means you don't like this girl,
you know lover.
I should say.
Maybe you love her,
but not that way.
Dumper and get with this girl.
All right,
and see where this fucking goes and hold back your heart though for a minute.
This girl might be a fucking killer toe.
She might be a,
uh,
a study on the other side of the fence since she's gonna fucking break your
heart.
So just,
uh,
see where it goes.
I'm already saying that before I get to the end of this.
Anyways,
he goes,
I get in the car and I realize I haven't seen the picture of my girlfriend.
Yeah.
She never sent it to me.
Perhaps she didn't like it or perhaps it was for someone else.
What the fuck just happened?
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
You guessed it.
A picture of my girlfriend topless to girls swiped back immediately and I just
stood there,
took it all in.
She said,
good for you.
That broke the ice.
We kind of joked around before and after the senses I get in the car and I
realized I haven't seen the picture of my girlfriend.
She never sent it to me.
Oh.
Cause it was on her phone.
Oh wait.
She sent it to somebody else.
Do this is like a great movie.
Perhaps she did.